yo i'm kind of worried about the volcano
did you see how many titans tested
positive for lava
ignore all that man it's the freaking
quarter season carnival
yo what up i got a quick pass much love
i love to feel the air through my hair
pump hey guys
that's how you slide cool i keep waiting
by doing wacky
don't worry loser still gets a pride
whoa i don't want that
i think i could do this with better
coaching but at this point i'm not sure
i'm daddy dimes and i shoot like this oh
step right up to the tunnel of jordan
love a ride that's more scared of me
than i am of it
so back when i was playing in denver
wait i was never on the broncos how was
i never on the broncos why doesn't
berlin have them indoors
are you sure you're still a good fit
there yes i fit the bar's just too high
if you could just
lower the bar for me do not bumble with
the bar can everyone stop
questioning my decision maker love
[Music]
when i first joined the league there was
no red zone you to go back and forth
between the channels yourself by sunday
night your thumb will be throbbing
you know they used to let defenders on
the cover of madden you know these la
rams are so spoiled the st louis rams
played in the shed
and loved it so carson palmer says to
matt hasselbeck stop hassling
my back write this down kid this is good
[Music]
stuff
[Music]
you